Feynman diagrams are very useful
because they take the complicated
and abstract mathematics of particle interactions
and show the equations as simple pictures of
what happens when subatomic particles interact.
The axes of feynman diagrams are space and time,
and the different particles get different lines:
a photon is a wiggle, the gluons are
spirals, the W and Z bosons and the
Higgs boson get a dotted line, and the
fermions get straight lines with arrows.
These arrows point forwards in time for matter
particles and backwards in time for antimatter
particles, and the arrows always flow from
one side of the diagram to the other.
The building blocks of Feynman diagrams are
vertices which are a joining point between
three particles. The orientation of these
vertices changes the story they are telling.
This one shows an electron changing
momentum when it emits a photon.
But if we rotate it, it shows an electron
and a positron annihilation into a photon.
You can build most Feynman diagrams
from this set of vertices, like this,
or this. If you want to be able to make sense of
these check out my full video in the description.